You can hear me ?
Here we go.
Thank you,
Mr Hillier,
that's for the introduction and also for
the invitation.
So not everyone will invite me places.
So it's nice when an invitation shows
up,
yeah and when I'm actually allowed to
speak,
that's also good.
So I have a habit of not preparing my
talks until really the last minute.
And I mean that's not exactly true
because I've been thinking about what
I'm going to talk to you about tonight
for a very long time,
but I really only got the title for this
talk firmly in place about half an hour
ago.
And,
and one of the things I like to do when
I'm speaking to people is to tell them
what I'm thinking about,
not what I've already thought about,
you know,
and certainly not what I know,
but what I'm thinking about,
what I'm trying to figure out.
And so one of the things that's happened
to me over the last year,
somewhat surprisingly,
is that I've been invited to speak in
front of a lot of conservative groups
and uh,
a lot of them were conservative groups
that were composed of young people.
And that was interesting,
you know,
because conservatism isn't something
that's necessarily all that easy to sell
to young people because they tend not to
be that conservative to begin with.
And conservatism also tends to have
quite a lot to do with things that you
shouldn't do and instead of things that
you might be allowed to do.
And so there's a restrictive element of
it that's also perhaps less attractive
to young people than it might be.
People do tend to get more conservative
as they get older,
as their personality shift.
And so,
but what I saw was very interesting
because I saw this was particularly true
of young men and I haven't quite puzzled
that out yet,
but,
you know,
I would talk about what was going on in
the universities and what I thought
might constitute a reasonable antidote
to that.
And that was,
uh,
not only in the universities but also
politically,
but,
and that was both the adoption of
responsibility instead of the incredible
and constant stress that's being placed
on rights and also the responsibility of
the citizen to speak forward what he or
she believed to be true or at least to
not speak what they knew to be false,
which is at least a good place to start.
And one of the things I found so
remarkable was that this was actually a
salable message to young people.
And that surprised me because you know,
you wouldn't necessarily think that you
would turn a lot of lights on in a young
audience by talking to people about
truth and responsibility.
I think if you,
if you went to a marketing agency and
told them that that was going to be your
political message to young people,
they would tell you to go back and,
you know,
flesh out another plan,
sketch out another plan.
But maybe young people have been talked
to enough about rights for maybe about
the next 15 decades.
That's what I would think.
And so maybe there's a hunger a among
young people for something that has a
little bit more respectability,
let's say,
a little bit more depth than the
constant emphasis on,
on
doing whatever you want,
whenever you want.
Let's let's put it that way.
The thing about that,
and the thing about rights in general,
the idea of rights is that rights don't
really give you much direction,
right?
They,
they,
they tell you what you are in principal
allowed to do,
but they don't really tell you what you
should do.
And it actually turns out that you need
to know what you should do because you
need to do something right.
People are active and our lives don't
have any meeting without something to do
and,
and something that you should do.
It can't just be something that you want
to do that's too shallow.
There's no deep meaning.
There's no enduring,
there's no sustaining meaning in that.
It's just impulsiveness and,
and the.
And maybe that's okay.
In some sense,
maybe that's entertaining and maybe it's
and maybe it's impulsively exciting and
fun and there's some,
there's some utility in that for life.
But life is a very difficult journey,
let's say it involves a lot of suffering
and it involves a lot of,
of heavy existential weight and you need
to be able to put something,
a value up against that so that you can
withstand your life and you can stand up
with some dignity and you can contribute
to your community and you can feel that
you're a worthwhile person,
you know,
in spite of all the things that are,
that you're doing wrong and in spite of
all the problems that you have.
And so then people need to know what
they should do and one of the things
they should do is take responsibility.
And another thing they should do is try
to tell the truth because those two
things help them live proper lives and
then help society organizes itself
properly.
And that's,
that's good,
that's good for everyone.
So,
and so it turns out that when you tell
young people that they're pretty damn
happy about that.
And so one of the things I thought I
would do tonight is talk about what
conservatives might have to offer to
young people as a saleable message.
You know,
because my,
the other thing I've learned over the
last year,
and this was quite
revealing,
let's put it that way.
I'll start with a brief story just as a
little intro to this.
In the last three weeks,
some of you may know that there was
quite a political storm that emerged
particularly among journalists over the
issue of cultural appropriation.
A number of journalists got in real
trouble for transgressing the
politically correct norms in
relationship to cultural appropriation,
a tremendously ill defined,
and let's call it pathological concept.
We could start with that,
but.
But the thing that was so interesting
and I think I probably talked to 10 of
Canada's top 20 journalists.
That would be a reasonable estimate.
Most of them in print,
but not all of them.
Every single one of them told me that
they were censoring themselves.
Or you think about that man,
that's no joke.
In a country like this and these people,
you think,
well,
if anyone has power,
they have power.
It's like,
well,
they don't really have power.
They have competence and influence and
that's not the same thing as power and
they're bloody afraid of being hung out
to dry if they say the wrong thing.
You think about where our damn country
is.
When the 10 most powerful journalists in
the country are afraid to write and say
what they think,
that's not a good thing,
man.
That's not a good thing.
I don't care what it is that they want
to say or think the fact that they're
not only did they tell me that they were
censoring themselves and that they felt
that they would be hung out to dry if
they said the wrong thing,
but they also told me that they were
being censored by their editors and so
you know,
in a country that has a great tradition
and a tradition that's much longer than
this country has been around of freedom
and free speech and free press.
For us to be in this situation now where
our major journalists are afraid that if
they misstep inappropriately in this new
found political landmine that they're
going to be done.
That is not good.
Right?
That's a bad diagnostic sign.
Okay.
Well,
I said that story was a little intro to
the other story was going to tell you
and then so I've been fortunate enough
over the last several months to meet not
the majority of the people who ran for
the leadership of the Federal
Conservative Party,
but most of them,
including the people,
the person who Andrew,
who recently won and uh,
they all told me the same thing,
which was also interesting was that the
conservatives were afraid to be
conservative and if for exactly the same
reason,
they were afraid that if they put
forward valid conservative perspectives
that they would be isolated and mobbed
and taken down and,
and that made them censor themselves and
not be willing to speak up.
And I thought,
and I told each of them when we
discussed this,
the same thing was if you guys are
afraid to talk,
you've already lost.
You might as well just pack up and go
home.
It's done now,
you know,
as a psychologist.
Thank you.
Fuck,
I got to say,
I'm not making a case for conservatism.
I'm not here to make a political case.
Right?
I'm here to make a philosophical and
psychological case and I think that's
what I've been doing all along.
It has political implications,
so I'm not saying that you should be
conservative or that conservative is the
only way to be because I actually don't
believe that for for a variety of
reasons.
One of the reasons is that I know that
political belief is determined in large
part by temperament and personality and
that's very strongly biologically
influenced and so conservatives tend to
be lower and openness,
which is a trait associated with
creativity and hiring conscientiousness,
industriousness and orderliness.
They tend to make good managers and
administrators and lawyers.
They tend to make good conservative
business types.
That's,
that's their forte,
that's their niche and that's a valid
place to be in a valid thing to be and
you know,
conservatives aren't so good at being
entrepreneurial and they're not so good
at being artistic and creative.
That's not their niche.
That's more the niche of the liberal end
of the spectrum and as far as I'm
concerned,
for the political system to function
properly,
you need proper representation for all
the temperamental types and they need to
be engaged in dialogue.
So.
But the thing is is that when the
conservatives are saying,
well,
you know,
especially when they're perhaps thinking
about leading the damn party,
let's say that they're worried about
speaking their mind in a conservative
manner.
That's just not a good thing.
That means that something's gone wrong
with our political system and seriously
wrong.
You know,
when.
The other thing that.
Another thing that I've noticed it
thing,
you know,
when,
when this all.
Some of you may know in some of you may
not know that I made a couple of videos
back September 27th.
I woke up one night because I couldn't
sleep and I thought,
are you usually going right if I can't
sleep because I've got something to
figure out.
But I've been playing with youtube
videos.
I've been putting my lectures online
since 2013 and by last April they had
about a million views.
And so I thought,
wow,
that's,
that's really something,
man,
you know,
like you write a book and you sell a
million copies,
you're one happy character.
And I thought a million views is a very
large number of views.
It really tuned me into the fact that
youtube was something completely other
than what I thought it was.
But anyways,
that night I thought,
oh,
I'll get up,
I'll make a video instead of writing it
down.
And this was a video about bill
[inaudible],
which by the way,
the Senate just passed,
right?
Half the conservatives voted for it,
despite the fact that the justice
minister was presented with an amendment
that clearly indicated that bill see 16
would not infringe upon free speech and
refused to consider the amendment.
So that's where we are.
There's compelled speech is now.
The law in Canada isn't yet,
but it's going to be very soon and half
the conservatives voted for that damn
bill.
And I can tell you to,
you know,
people have gotten after me for being,
anti transgender and bigoted and phobic
and all that nonsense that the left
tends to hurl at people.
It's not the case.
I read that damn legislation and I read
the policies surrounding it and I knew
perfectly well that the way it's
formulated right now,
it will do more harm to the people that
purports to protect then good.
That'll take about 10 years to unfold,
but it's so incoherent and the the the
principles upon which that legislation
and it's surrounding policies are based,
are so paradoxical and contradictory
that they will act themselves out
because that's what happens with
paradoxical beliefs and tangled people
up like the men that tight tangle people
up in them like mad and we'll see that
happen over the next decade and it's
partly because the people who put bill
60 [inaudible] forward,
especially with regards to its
surrounding policies.
The ones that are detailed out on the
Ontario Human Rights Commission website
don't give a damn about transgendered
people.
As far as I'm concerned there.
There's another agenda at work that's
driving their entire political force
forward and the transgender types.
We're just flavor of the month,
right?
They were poster boys for moving this
postmodern agenda forward and so the
fact that the legislation isn't going to
do them any good during the
transgendered people any good isn't
going to stop the people who put the
legislation forward.
So anyways,
I made these videos and I put them on a,
on youtube and well to say that they
caused a storm,
which is somewhat of an understatement.
I mean it's just been.
I just,
I,
I don't even know what to think about.
It's completely and absolutely surreal
what,
what's happened to me like as a
consequence of that,
I mean I don't know how many people have
watched those original videos,
like $350,000.
I think now about 50 million people have
watched videos associated with this
sequence of events that I'm describing,
which is just 350,000
people watched the testimony that I gave
before the Senate on bill [inaudible].
You bloody well know that the apocalypse
is close when 350,000
people around the world watch a Canadian
Senate hearing.
So I really,
I mean really what's going on man?
So anyways,
you know,
so,
I said,
well the journalists are nervous and
the,
and the,
the part where they're conservatives are
nervous and,
and uh,
well then,
you know,
when I,
when I put myself out and made these
videos,
which are really didn't expect to
attract much attention at all,
I just assumed that I was going to
clarify what I was thinking a little bit
and you know,
to see what happened.
I kind of a curious person now that'll
teach me but I'm kind of a curious
person.
And so,
um,
but then,
you know,
I also experienced firsthand what
happens when you do something like that.
Now I got nailed right.
I got especially for about three months,
things were pretty up in the air at the
university sent me two letters telling
me that it was so funny because I've
made this video and I said,
you know,
under this new legislation,
making this video,
criticizing this legislation is probably
illegal.
And so then the unit and people of
course reacted to me as if I was
scaremongering,
which by the way was the right response.
When you hear someone in a stable
society stand up and say,
excuse me,
there's a,
there's something rotten at the base
here,
and it's affecting the manner in which
the legislation that our country is
producing is,
is,
is being rolled fourth,
when they say that you should think that
person is probably a charlatan and has
something wrong with them because look,
the culture works pretty good.
The has worked really well for a long
period of time,
and so the logical initial response
should be,
yeah,
you think there's a fundamental problem,
why shouldn't we just assume that
there's a fundamental problem with you?
And one of the ways that you determined
that is you throw things out the person
metaphorically and see if any of them
stick,
right?
So,
you know,
I was a big homophobic and transphobic
and a racist.
That one,
I don't know where the hell that one
came from.
I think it was because I,
I,
I criticize the two.
Uh,
what would you call reprehensible women
who started black lives,
black lives matter movement,
Toronto.
It isn't because they're black.
It's because they're reprehensible,
black or white.
Man.
If you're reprehensible,
your reprehensible,
that's sort of the definition of not
being racist.
Right.
So
anyways,
so,
so there were a couple of demonstrations
and then the press jumped on me to some
degree.
They didn't do too bad a job I didn't
think and then the university thankfully
wrote two letters saying that what I was
doing was probably illegal and that it
violated the,
the Ontario Human Rights Commission's
policies and probably the university's
policies as well as far as they were
concerned,
which really wasn't the case and the
letters also contained a number of
untruths which I detailed because I read
them on Youtube too,
which is actually quite helpful and
handy that you know,
if someone writes me a letter that
purports to lay out a set of facts,
then I can just read it.
I don't even have to comment on it.
I can read it and let people make up
their own minds,
which they did so,
so well.
And so my job was in,
in,
in doubt.
But the fact that the university went
after me actually turned out to be
extremely helpful.
Right.
Because I had said,
look under the provisions of this new
legislation and legislation like this
that's already in place in Canada,
what I am doing criticizing this bill is
probably illegal.
And everyone said,
no,
you're crazy.
You know you're,
there's something wrong with you.
You're a,
you're a,
you're a scaremonger.
And a rabble rouser and all of that.
And then the university wrote a letter
saying what you did violated the,
you know,
the university policy and probably the
Ontario Human Rights Commission's
policies and the law.
And I thought,
great,
you had your lawyers take a look at it.
I couldn't have asked for a more
stronger statement,
a stronger statement in support of what
I had said,
especially because it certainly wasn't
written in support of what I had set.
So,
and then the journalist started to pay
attention to what I had actually looked
at and they read it and they thought,
Oh hey,
look at that.
That don't that ordinary human rights
commission website policy mass is
actually quite a nest of spiders.
Just like he said.